Nvidia is going to be the world's
largest company for years haters have
been saying that nvidia's time at the
top is almost over as soon as the custom
PC hype dies down Nvidia will get
crushed as soon as the Bitcoin mining
craze ends Nvidia will get decimated but
time and time again Nvidia has shown
more resilience than any big Tech stock
on the market but that's not to say that
the haters don't have some valid
concerns like nvidia's valuation Nvidia
Miss hands down the most richly valued
big tech company even more richly valued
than Tesla but just because Nvidia has a
rich valuation and doesn't mean that
they won't continue growing in terms of
fundamentals and a market cap in fact
it's highly likely that this is the case
they've got a foot in consumer grade
products afford in Enterprise grade
products and a ginormous foot in AI